the jurogan experience the highest i
have ever been
on a podcast was with be real when i did
uh
smoke box smoke box right that's what he
calls it
b real smoke box he's got a car and it's
they have a set up inside the car and
there's the cameras in there and so we
got high first oh jesus like barbecued
and then you get in the car and everyone
keeps smoking and they just keep smoking
i'm like oh my god
yeah it happened to me once with uh nick
and nate talk talked me to smoking right
before in a hotbox car we just got so
lit remember they put me in i'm in the
cage my gloves taped on headgear taped
on looking across at nick and i'm like
wait i gotta fight this guy right now
i got so scared we're barbecued here
i'm so high i already stopped smoking
i'm just going let me off
it's legit in terms of
yes crazy how much some people could
smoke those guys can put it down is nick
fighting again
i don't know you know he's he for his
last fight obviously he wasn't in the
best situation you know mentally and
stuff so i i would like to see him fight
again but like him do a proper camp so
i just saw something uh yesterday that's
why i was gonna ask um something that
said uh nick diaz plans to return
i think he wants to but i really hope he
does a proper camp and does it right
because uh what did he do for the last
one
not much really i think he was just
going through some tough times in his
life and uh you know i don't want to get
into his personal life too much but i
think he was going through uh through a
tough time and i don't i don't think i
would have liked to have pulled the
fight and moved it back personally coach
expect nick diaz to fight by the end of
the year coach cesar gracie gives an
update on his longtime protege mma
veteran and fan favorite nick diaz so
yeah so people were like thinking that
he was kind of heavy and that's why the
fight want to be they they fought at 85
right i think they moved to 85 yeah
which lawler's a big guy too i'm sure he
didn't mind oh he's probably so happy he
didn't have to cut you know
yeah i think a lot of it was his
motivation he was kind of like pushed
into the the fight happened so quick and
he hadn't been training at all then all
of a sudden he's like fighting in two
months it was just kind of rushed you
didn't have to do a camp but you know
because nick's like a brother i really
hope he fights again but he needs to
make sure to properly do a camp
the amount of love that that guy gets is
off the charts when they see him you
know love him when they introduced him
during that fight too the whole audience
went crazy yeah he's an absolute legend
like everyone loves nick diaz i mean
he's a very important part of uh the
emma the history of mma and if people
don't realize what a big party is you
need to watch him in the strike force
days because when he was a strikeforce
champion you watched the frank shamrock
fight
you know watch uh
wow that's probably the best one round
fight i've ever seen amazing fights
cyborg the cyborg
gomi yes watch those days he's he's a
true legend
everyone loves him so some people forget
like how great he was oh my god the paul
daley fight is an insane fight because
daley has one of the best left hands in
the history of the sport daley was a
thunderous striker he was so dangerous
yeah he's he's tough was he one of wha
so
henderson hit you hardest probably
henderson yeah but he landed clean daley
didn't land anything too clean he'll pop
me with a jab that was like oh wow that
uh this guy's got some power he has
i better i better take him down in top
mount yeah i mean he knocked out lorenzo
larkin he's savage yeah amazing power
and um
so
nick just went at him
in that fight you watched that fight oh
yeah nick just swarmed him and just the
volume of strikes like you can see like
the that kind of fight is where he
thrived
he got dropped in that fight drop kick
but even when you get dropped he's like
moving around on the ground avoiding the
ground pound gets back up and he talks
so much [ __ ] to guys yeah during during
during the sparring
they're talking [ __ ] hilarious that's
one of the things that frank shamrock
said about fighting him like you can't
believe he's talking [ __ ] to you while
he's beating you up yeah it just adds uh
adds humiliation to it
also like frustration
like it's hard to like keep your head
straight yeah that the gomi fights one
of my favorite fights that one was
amazing that was incredible when he
tapped out gomi and yeah
he got cracked right before that too
remember
that was when was gomi
you know yeah yeah he's one of the best
oh my god gomi was one of those guys
from japan that was so fierce
sakurai was another one i fought him oh
that was crazy that was my first big one
i went to japan i never left the country
never been on a plane and i flew out to
japan
with nick diaz that was wild what was
the event
trudeau oh wow yeah he was ranked like
number two in the world at the time i
was completely unknown that was like for
me that's one of my most memorable
fights even though like most people in
the u.s didn't watch it it was like such
a cool experience